اللهم صل على محمد وال محمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
استووا واعتدلوا
شولدر حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سبحانك اللهمك
اسمك وتعك
الهك
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد ذانا لجهنم
كثيرا من الجن والانس لهم قلوب لا يفقهون
بها
لهم قلوب لا يفقهون بها ولهم اعين لا
يبصرون بها
ولهم اذان لا يسمعون بها اولئك
كالانعام
بل هم اضل اولئك
هم الغافلون
ولله الاسماء اسماء
الحسنى فادعوه بها
وذروا الذين يلحدون في اسمائه
سيجزون ما كانوا يعملون
ومن وممن خلقنا امه يهدون بالحق وبه
يعدلون
والذين كذبوا باياتنا
سنستدرجهم
من حيث لا يعلمون
واملي لهم ان كيدي متين
اولم يتفكروا
ما بصاحبهم
من جنه
ان هو الا نذير مبين
اولم ينظروا في ملكوت السما السماوات
والارض وما خلق الله من شيء
وان عسى ان يكون قد اقترب اجلهم
فباي حديث بعده يؤمنون
من يضلل الله فلا هادي له ويذرهم في
طغيانهم يعمهون
يسال يسالونك عن الساعه ايان مرساها
قل انما علمها عند ربي
لا يجليها
لوقتها الا هو ثقلت في السماوات والارض لا
تاتيكم الا بغتا يسالونك كانك حفي عنها
قل انما علمها عند الله ولكن اكثر الناس
لا يعلمون
الله
اكبر
سبحان ربي العظيم
سبحان ربي العظيم سبحان رب العظيم
سمع الله
لمن حمده
طيبا مباركا فيه ملا السماوات ومن الارض
ومن ما بينهما ومن
الله
اكبر
سبحان ربي سبحان ربنا
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر سبحان
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قل لا املك لنفسي نفعا ولا ضرا الا ما شاء
الله
ولو كنت اعلم الغيب لاستكثرت من الخير وما
مسني السوء
ان انا الا نذير وبشير لقوم يؤمنون
هو الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وجعل منها زوجها
وجعل منها زوجها ليسكن اليها
فلما
تغشاها حملت حملا خفيفا فمرت به فلما
اثقلت دعوى الله ربهما
دعو الله ربهما لئن اتيتنا صالحا لنكونن
من الشاكرين
فلما
اتاهما صالحا جعلا له شركاء
جعلا له شركاء
فيما اتاهما
فتعالى الله عما
يشركون
الله
اكبر سبحان ربي سبحان رب سبحان رب
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
النبي ورحمه الله وبركاته
السلام علينا وعلى
الصالحين نشهد ان لا اله الا الله ونشهد
ان محمدا عبده
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
واياك نستعين
صراط الذين
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن من حمدا
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر بسم
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
السلام علينا وعلى عباد الصالحين اشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان
رسول الله صل على
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
انت السلام ومنك السلام وتبارك الجلال
المتكرم لا اله الا الله
لا شريك له
على كل شيء
اللهم لاع ماطيت ولا
لا اله الا
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد الله سبحانه وتعالى
سهران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سبحانه وتعالى
وما يذكرون
الا ان يشاء الله
هو اهل التقوى واهل المغفره
سبحانه وتعالى
قران
الله سبحانه وتعالى
تذكره
‏I mean the knowledge in the Quran
before teaches us from the very first
revelation
it was ainder
what is itinding us ofinding
us of something that it hasn't yet us no
‏way
of that which is in our
that which we were created upon the
created us upon
it is a comp of morality
is something that is beond needing to
lically
we to say what
الله
compes
lying is steing islicting
on other without
‏a ofice
that there is
that been created by someone for
that the is above me
is not every hea
is one all of things we know because of
what because of our are things that are
beond
logically having to prove
[Silence]
‏damaged by
damaged every time we ignore it and go
against
فطره bec
beced.
Bec unclear
انسو الله سبحانه وتعالى senders
with toind usind
us of natural disposition to reset the
scales
to return us to the disposition and the
purpose of our existence
that is whatahى
سوره النور
الله سبحانه وتعالى
نور
على نور
يهدي الله لنوره من يشاء
سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏was upon and our sense of direction
isn't enough to guide us
الله سبحانه وى
اللهر
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏are
place life in our dire to
so the natural disposition of Allah الله
Allah mentions this natural disposition
throughout the quran and in the very
wellnar
من الصحيحين
صلى الله عليه وسلم
كل مولود يولد على على ايش؟ على الفطره
فابواه
يهودانه
او ينصرانه
او يمجسانه
صلى الله عليه
فطره
فطره الله التي فطر الناس عليها
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏have
we don't have that steing is telling the
truth is right that courage is
commendable that val is good that
stinginess is bad that deception and
treachery are bad
and so we know these things how because
we were created for exactly
‏and things about
things about the specific are by the b
of
the ages so wheners to theرانذ
ainder
to the who is justing
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏of being have always
and what is that
being have
the human being free will
or is the human being atom that has no
choice and we are but biological
‏dire
الله سبحانه وتعالى
بل الانسان على نفسه بصيره
‏to
that being is enough of a wit over
why do we have
why do we have judges why do we have
laws
why do we have these things allies
everyety why because weve all agreed
that we have free will we have free
‏our
free will
humanity has always been of three
opinions in this is still till today
even scien
all scientific research when
‏where come
to where are goingever
back to
ultimevert back to belief and disbelief
they say philosopy but it's not
philosopy revelation of subانه
the first is people that they are
complely
‏have
any ch that make for them by
the other
is we only have free will and there is
no decree there is no higher force or
higher one that has written our destiny
destiny
‏Now as
we are just enough of the decree of
Allah
to
know that we have free will but that our
free will is destined.
‏Does everyone understand this concept?
No, few will understand it. And it's
been said ancient by by the scholarship
of Islam
that
decree and destiny it's the secret of
Allah subhanah wa few men have been
given understanding of the decree of
Allah. And it's a dangerous toic.
صلى الله عليه وسلم
في حديث حسن اذا ذكرت النجوم فامسكوا
واذا ذكر اصحابي فامسكوا
واذا ذكر القدر فامسكوا ايش يعني فامسكوا
فامسكوا عن الكلام والخوض
في هذه المخاط
صلى الله عليه
‏my comp are
and
are mention
and if deree is mentionedra
from whatra
from debating theil of ises in
the comp of the propacy
is
صلى الله عليه وسلم
between
smallر
‏The stars serve as adornment of the
sky.
The stars serve as a guidance for the
lost and the traveler.
‏And the stars serve to
guard the heavens from the intrusions of
the
anything beyond this refrain.
‏from what horoscopes andyils
why are they are what this me and what
do they have on the are told us beond
that
and say if derecee is mention
what part ofree theil ofree
not
الله
سبحانه وى
اللهم
ر
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وما يذكرون
الا ان يشاء
‏gu take
and gucept
those الله
will
gu thoseek gu
and seek
‏herey
and free will and will
ان الله تعالى
باذن الله تعالى سوره المزمل سوره المزمل
سوره القلم سوره نون ان شاء الله تعالى
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يهدينا سواء
السبيل اسال الله تعالى ان يجعلني واياكم
ممن يستمعون القول فيتبعون احسنه والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد